here in this video we shall rank the top
10 most destructive godzilla
incarnations and
we will do it by assessing the amount of
damage each godzilla has done
over the course of their appearance in
their own respective movies
of course the big g is sometimes
portrayed as the good guy
and as the main villain in others
nevertheless
he has always caused mayhem wherever he
goes whether to cities
countries or even the planet itself so
subscribe if you haven't already
remember to hit that like button and now
let's get down with this mayhem
number 10 godzilla 1984 on the bottom of
this list we have the early heisei
godzilla of 1984 and 1985
set as a sequel to the original 1954
movie a new godzilla awakens and attacks
japan
more specifically tokyo godzilla first
attacks the e hammer nuclear power
station
in shizuoka prefecture and then combats
with a super x weapon and then chases it
through several skyscrapers
destroying them and finally kicks its
butt by making another skyscraper
falling on top of the super x weapon
but fortunately the destruction was
ended when godzilla was lured and
trapped inside a volcano
number nine godzilla 1993. next on the
list we have another heisei godzilla
from the 1993 movie
and it wasn't tokyo but kyoto that faced
the rage of godzilla
and mecca godzilla and well in the first
battle it was seen
godzilla had the upper hand against the
mecca and yet on the second one
mechagodzilla won the round
only two lose on the last round it was
seen that godzilla just causes mayhem
wherever he goes just
by walking through large buildings and
taking down skyscrapers and towers
in search of godzilla junior and in the
final battle he vaporized an entire
stadium and took down a few skyscrapers
as well
number eight godzilla 1991 godzilla from
the movie godzilla vs mecca king
ghidorah
has the eighth spot and along with
ghidorah they both destroyed a lot of
buildings in tokyo
godzilla vs king ghidorah had a complex
and somewhat confusing plot involving
aliens time travel
and world war ii but perhaps more
importantly
it also features a few memorable attacks
on tokyo city
which sees godzilla vaporizer's
buildings and during his fight would
make a king ghidorah
entire city blocks were leveled down
number seven final wars godzilla
on a number seven spot we have godzilla
from final wars and this version causes
destruction in two cities
not one sydney and tokyo in sydney he
faced up against zillow which he easily
defeated and in the process destroys the
opera house
and in tokyo he faced up against dragon
and monster x
the resulting fight with both these
kaiju and keizer ghidorah in the end
transformed tokyo into rubble
it is also notable that the g-man before
this went on
a rampage killing all the kaiju that
stood on his way
number six godzilla 1995. in the movie
godzilla vs destoroyah both these kaiju
laid ways to the city of hong kong
and godzilla in his fire form was very
destructive in his rampage and revenge
on destoroyah
in the battle godzilla goes on to
nuclear meltdown and would have
destroyed the entire planet if that
happened
and thankfully the jsdf is able to
minimize the damage with the freezer
weapons
while successful in preventing earth's
destruction the jsdf
is unable to prevent the massive nuclear
fallout from rendering
tokyo uninhabitable number five the
original godzilla
of course we have the first godzilla and
he hosts the number five spot on this
list
this was the horror that the atomic
bombing of hiroshima and nagasaki was
made incarnate into this kaiju and
ghazal was the embodiment of nuclear
destruction and as such was nigh
indestructible
as to why he is on a number 5 spot well
it was
one of the first time ever that an
entire city was seen being destroyed
in the movie screens and yes by a
monster and it was horrifying to the
generation that witnessed it the first
time
number 4 godzilla's singular point the
newest entry
of the incarnation of godzilla this
version was
similar to shin godzilla as he causes
unbelievable destruction to the city of
tokyo
and also it was evolving very fast as
godzilla initially emerges as an aquatic
animal
and evolves several times into the final
altima stage
in this form he emits a red dust element
that envelops the entire city as well as
causing mayhem wherever he went his
atomic breath can slice through
buildings like a knife through butter
but his death was the reason why he's on
the fourth spot
because when he died he exploded into
blue crystals that impaled the entire
city
number 3 shin godzilla on the third spot
we have another hyper-evolving godzilla
and this was seen in the 2016 movie
shin godzilla in which tokyo again bore
the wrath of the g-man
godzilla initially came into the city as
a wriggling sickly form but
even then causes havoc in the streets in
the third form he was taking down
buildings and finally in his fourth form
the amount of destruction he can cause
was immense
as even with the thermal belt flame he
was able to burn down
dozens of city blocks and his beam
attacks can slice through buildings
kilometers away
with ease number two most diverse
godzilla
well legendary's entry made it to the
second spot as he was seen to wreak
havoc in hawaii
san francisco boston hong kong the us
navy
and even boring a hole to the hollow
earth a feat that was not seen in
any other godzilla before it and after
it as well
although the destruction two cities were
maybe not intentional the attack on
pensacola the navy
carrying calm and in and both in boston
and tokyo they nearly brought the cities
to the ground
but the most impressive display was the
atomic breath boring a hole thousands of
kilometers deep
and number one of course godzilla earth
and lastly we have the godzilla earth
who not only survived hundreds of
nuclear weapons fight on him but also
laid waste
to the entire planet in the course of
time transforming it into an alien
planet
one that was unrecognizable and in the
near future
the godzilla earth emerges along with
many kaiju but
in the end godzilla manages to kill off
all this kaiju and caused the human
civilization to go to the brink of
extinction and earth was transformed
into
more or less an extension of himself his
atomic breath and tail swipe alone can
put series into rubble with one shot
and with this we come to the end of the
video of the top 10 most destructive
godzilla incarnations
please leave a like button for support
and subscribe to be a part of the mind
cue family
wait do put in your thoughts down below
as well as we want to know what you
think about this video
and smash that bell button for regular
updates on new master content
right here on this channel till the next
one take care fam